the day after Trump was found liable for
sexual assault and defamation of e Gene
Carroll uh in order to pay her five
million dollars he went on his CNN Town
Hall
and he made more disparaging comments
about Eugene Carroll and many of us said
sounds like potentially more defamation
CNBC reports Trump faces a 10 million
dollar defamation Claim by E.G Carroll
after his CNN Town Hall remarks
so at this point will e Gene Carroll be
able to collect these millions I don't
actually know the answer to that legal
experts who have weighed in say probably
but it could take a while
and now you may be adding even more on
to it is Trump doing this because he
genuinely thinks he's never going to pay
is it because he doesn't care about the
money which would be very much unlike
Trump or is he just confused about what
defamation even is